6-5-3 ON THE
ROAD.
CURRENTLY IN A PLAYOFF SPOT IN
THIRD IN THE OFF THE GAME AGAINT
ST. LOUIS OUT IN FRONT.
THE DEFENSEMAN,
DRIEDGER, AND SEATTLE, GETS OUT
TEAM, AS INDICATED BY THE STAT
>> J.T.: L.A. WITH A COUPLE OF
OPPORTUNITIES. DANAULT,
WILL GET TO IT.
ONE-TOUCH PASS THROUGH THE
MIDDLE.
TO
THE KRAKEN.
>> J.T.: ALLOWING DRIEDGER TO
KOPITAR.
MUSC
KOPITAR,ATTA,
DANAULT.
AND NOW,OUR POINT, THE FIRST
TWO
ARE YOU LOOKING AT BLACKWELL,
ZONE.
AND AERIAL FLIP.
POSITION.RTED BYFRONT. BROKEN UY
THE NEXT ONE, A LOT OFFOLLOW-UP.
DANAUL MOVING PART.
YOU HAVE TO KEEP TRACK BROKEN UN
THE BACK-CHECK BY MCCANN.STOPPE
SCORE! IS A GOOD T MCCANN.
GIORDANO, MCCANN,
>> J.T.: READY FOR THE SEC
BLACKWELL, GOOD WORK TO GET IT.
AREA.
THAT PUCK, SO MUCH MOVEMEN THIN-
EBERLE, CHANGES FOR THE
GOALTENDER.
DANAULT, OPEN NET.
ANGLED
DANAULT.
A GREAT MOVE.
HE IS ABLE TO BEAT